our next guest shot bin laden in the
face
joining me now is navy seal rob o'neal
rob 20 years a lot of thoughts a lot of
experiences
people know you from the bin laden raid
but you've spent multiple tours over
many years in afghanistan
am i off base here um i think you're
completely
on base pete and thanks for having me
yeah
it's it's one of those places
afghanistan where
if you haven't been there you wouldn't
believe people yeah
one one of the best stories that i have
is um one of my interpreters who's also
my chef i got an argument with him one
time and i said you know address
if we surround afghanistan with a foot
wall that was electrified you wouldn't
have a television
in 10 000 years my country put a man on
the moon and back in 200 years and he
said mr rob you're so stupid you can't
put a man on the moon
it's this big and and that's the that's
i mean it some of these people they
don't they don't not only do they not
know how old they are they don't know
what time is it
it's a it's a different world um i've
seen true poverty that's
children with no clothes playing in
sewage
it's it's it's it's up is down down is
up
we can never install jeffersonian
democracy there they don't want it they
want their valleys one of the best
quotes that i've ever heard is uh
we have the watches but they have the
time and that's not to disparage
afghans we've met wonderful people over
there we get it but it's it's the other
side of the moon to your point it's an
entirely different world
we tried to build a top-down afghan army
and i'm sure you
you would have met the best trained
afghans there will be ones that will
stay to fight
but ultimately was your experience that
those
with the afghan national army if the
taliban's winning they're probably going
to that side
it is such a difficult uh place to be
that a lot of those people and and again
some of the best people i've ever met in
my life were afghanis costumes uh
some of the best people ever um they
they have pashtun wally which if you ask
for help they'll give it to you
but they they're they're also fighting
for money um haqqani network pays
taliban pays we pay um some you know
they don't want a uh um a propped up uh
proxy government they want something
that the people have and that's that's
what the taliban is they're gonna come
back in i mean it seems like yesterday
we're watching people
shave their beards and uh that was 20
years ago they're coming back yeah
simple real quick we're out of time but
when should we have left in your mind i
mean declared victory and said hey we've
done our people we
we we should have been out of there in
2003. i was there in 2005.
that's when we rescued the loan survivor
marcus patrell um
there's a big difference between cities
and valleys they want their valleys and
that's that's what they want
again they don't know what time is we
should have been out of there a long
time so true we should have kept air
bases like bagram and jalalabad
and uh to cross border for things like
bin laden yeah
or maybe after bin laden was killed as
well rob o'neil thank you so much for
the insight
the moon thank you this big i'll never
forget it hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else